[Aplausos]
crear ideas nuevas resolver problemas no
predecibles y pensamiento crítico son
tres de las habilidades más importantes
para el futuro del trabajo a nivel
mundial esto según el foro económico
mundial
hace
cerca de 30 años que vengo trabajando
con diversos de equipos
interdisciplinarios y en distintas
organizaciones sobre el impacto en los
cambios sociales en la educación en la
formación profesional y en en la
capacitación laboral
hace unos años
encontré un término interesante leí el
reporte horizonte que busca el impacto o
no cierto de las tecnologías emergentes
en la educación
y ahí mencionaban tres términos
enseñanza aprendizaje e integración
creativa los dos primeros yo lo manejaba
la enseñanza con que tiene que ver tiene
que ver con poder él tiene que ver con
el profesor que logra transmitir no es
cierto una clase a un grupo de
estudiantes la enseñanza en cambio tiene
que ver con lo que el estudiante tiene
que hacer es la actividad del estudiante
del aprendiz pero había un término ahí
allá atrás un poco olvidado que se
llamaba indagación creativa que tiene
que ver con lo extracurricular con lo
que no cabe en el currículum y ese
término me sonó algo interesante como
que era una música que yo había
escuchado antes y claro era un lugar que
yo había recorrido un espacio que yo
había recorrido en mi formación
profesional y en mis primeros años de
trabajo como psicólogo
ese era un lugar que tenía que ver con
los primeros talleres de creatividad que
vi en la universidad un viernes a las 8
de la noche cuando los estudiantes ya
estaban cansados o el taller de
liderazgo creativo en la secundaria un
sábado por la mañana no no eran los
lugar los horarios más premium pero era
ahí donde se realizaba la indagación
creativa si tú te pones a escudriñar en
ese patio trasero de la educación vas a
encontrar no sólo a la profesora de
teatro y su programa sino que vas a
encontrar también el taller de música el
de hip hop y al loco profesor con su
taller de arduino y ahora es taller de
juegos de tablero de juegos de mesa
llevamos a la educación
todas las actividades extracurriculares
las cosas que no caben en el currículum
oficial pues está ahí atrás en un patio
trasero pero qué cosas también vas a
encontrar ahí estos tres carteles
crear ideas nuevas resolver problemas
no predecibles y pensamiento crítico
increíble
la habilidad del futuro
en el patio trasero de nuestra educación
si tú tienes la oportunidad de
entrevistar o conversar con una persona
que trabaje en cambio climático' te vas
a dar cuenta que los especialistas no
están muy optimistas aunque nosotros a
nivel mundial realicemos los acuerdos de
parís no llegamos es planeta no resiste
de hecho ellos plantean que el término
cambio se queda corto y recientemente la
onu ha dicho que el término ocupar es
emergencia climática yo creo que la
educación pasa lo mismo yo creo que la
educación
nosotros estamos frente a una emergencia
educativa
la puerta revolución industrial trae de
la mano una serie de tecnologías que
tienen el mundo patas para arriba
uno de los conceptos más importantes en
el área de la educación del trabajo del
futuro es la automatización porque
porque tiene que ver con que las tareas
repetitivas especializadas y basadas en
datos son realizadas mejor por máquinas
que por humanos
ah mira qué interesante te suena de algo
estos términos
tarea repetitiva especializadas basadas
en datos a mí sí se parece a la escuela
a tu escuela acá en cuenca y a mi
escuela allá en temuco en chile
nuestro sistema educativo lo que está
haciendo es preparar a los jóvenes para
hacer actividades especializadas
para prepararse para trabajos
repetitivos y para memorizar gran
cantidad de datos
es imposible lo que estamos haciendo es
pedirle a los chicos que compitan con
las máquinas lo que está haciendo
nuestro sistema educativo es transformar
a nuestras niñas de niños en robots pero
ineficientes no van a poder competir con
las máquinas al menos no en estas tareas
qué va a ocurrir en el futuro con el
trabajo los especialistas plantean que
un entre un 65 y un 70 por ciento de los
puestos de trabajo en el mundo van a ser
destruidos
un 75 son cerca de 75 millones de
puestos de trabajo en los próximos 10
años
por eso
pero quiero mostrarte
este gráfico qué significa
algunos ustedes tienen una hoja como
esta que se la entregaron en la entrada
por favor mira conmigo las barras
las barras de la izquierda las barras
verdes
y representan en este gráfico a la
población mundial que tiene menos acceso
a la educación por lo tanto accedió a
trabajos básicos y mal remunerados
el centro de la hoja que es la mayor
parte de la población
en cambio ha accedido a una mejor
educación
ha trabajado por su educación y ha
logrado una educación técnica o
profesional universitaria
el área de la derecha de la hoja la
barra que están acá en la pantalla son
las personas que tienen acceso no es
cierto y tienen recursos para lograr la
mejor educación a nivel mundial
la mayor parte de la población la
mayoría de nosotros en este salón está
en el centro
salvo honrosas excepciones- nosotros
somos hijos del sistema educativo la
mayoría de nosotros somos los primeros
profesionales en nuestras familias
nosotros vemos la educación como un
medio para la movilidad social
en esta hoja yo hice un ejercicio use en
el centro los nombres de algunos amigos
o amigas que me han acompañado en mi
viaje educativo
te voy a pedir que tú hagas lo mismo
ahora en un minuto en el centro de la
hoja rápidamente anota 235 nombres de
las personas que tú crees a lo ahora por
favor de las personas que tú crees que
han estudiado y han logrado cambiar su
calidad de vida a través de
estudiar algo una carrera técnica o una
carrera universitaria tomemos en un
minuto para esto por favor
un nombre dos nombres es algo rápido
estamos listos
un poquito más
unos segundos más ok muy bien entonces
lo que vamos a hacer ahora
aquí vamos a hacer lo siguiente vas a
doblar la hoja como esta pre
precisaba cierto y debería quedarte
una hoja como esta
como está en la pantalla
qué ocurrió desapareció la franja del
centro
no te tengo buenas noticias la mayoría
de los trabajos
que se van a automatizar no están
ni a la izquierda
no es cierto en las barras verdes ni a
la derecha están en el centro de la hoja
la mayoría de los trabajos que se van a
automatizar son trabajos que están
haciendo personas que tienen trabajos
especializados que están haciendo tareas
repetitivas
y que administran gran cantidad de datos
en los próximos años los trabajos que
van a destruirse son los trabajos que
tienen que ver no es cierto con este
tipo de tareas
por eso digo que estamos en una
emergencia educativa
yo me pregunto
qué haría
un prócer de la educación
latinoamericana si estuviera acá con
nosotros hoy día
y aquí invite y dibuje un joven paulo
freire
quería un paulo freire en la era de la
internet del cambio climático y en la
era de la inclusión
conversé con una querida amiga marta
una amiga brasileña mi mentora y que
trabajó con paulo freire cuando freire
era joven y ella me dijo
entre muchas otras cosas me dijo el
joven freire lo que estaría haciendo es
que estaría inventando y diseminando por
el mundo juegos online pero no juegos en
que tendríamos que matar al oponente
sino juegos que tuvieran que ver con
resolver colaborativamente los problemas
de su localidad problemas económicos
problemas territoriales y problemas
relacionales
yo creo sinceramente que si paulo freire
estuviera vivo lo que estaría haciendo
es que nuevamente estaría trabajando por
una alfabetización pero esta vez por una
alfabetización creativa
ese joven freire estaría trabajando duro
en la alfabetización digital una
alfabetización ecológica e inclusiva
quienes tienen que hacerse cargo de esta
emergencia educativa todos nosotros
niñas niños jóvenes profesores
universitarios educadores de las
escuelas más alejadas de nuestra área
rural profesionales de diferentes
disciplinas y como lo podemos hacer yo
digo realizando conexiones que no sean
evidentes imagínate lo siguiente
imagínate que tenemos un laboratorio y
ponemos y entramos todos nosotros ahí y
ponemos sobre el mesón las mejores
tecnologías educativas que pueden haber
hoy día que habría y meditación por
supuesto
robótica educativa pensamiento de diseño
club este de obvio los soles de su gata
mientras de hecho si sugata mitra sexy
pablo freire estuviera vivo sería muy
amigo de su ata mitra y sus entornos de
aprendizaje auto organizado los soles
qué haríamos luego con toda esta
tecnología bueno hacerla converger y
hacer que se conecte lo más probable que
saldrían soluciones que tú ni te
imaginas
dentro
del trabajo que venimos realizando yo te
tengo a ti la siguiente invitación te
invito a que tomes acción
pero de una manera creativa no
necesitamos crear un nuevo currículum
oficial para todos porque sería hacer
algo lineal sería hacer nuevamente lo
mismo
lo que tenemos que hacer es crear
espacios crear espacios nuevos donde
nuestros chicos puedan crear y chicas
puedan crear ideas nuevas y resolver
problemas no predecibles y desarrollar
pensamiento crítico
lo que lo que te quiero invitar es a lo
siguiente pues como te decía no hacer
un programa oficial nuevamente sino que
lo que tenemos que hacer como dice
maturana es gatillar el sistema y
gritarlo con diferentes estímulos
pequeños experimentos necesitamos hacer
una gran cantidad de pequeños
experimentos diversos que hagan que
irritan el sistema que propongan nuevas
ideas
te invito a tomar acción te invito a
crear y diseñar la red de
experimentadores creativos que cambian
la educación en latinoamérica muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]